oh
oh Mary I could taste that burp
dude thanks what's up
man oh PR thank you how how you doing
Merry Christmas Chistmas what are you
sipping on oh it's probably going to
have to be blurred out but here take a
swig oh Trader shows peppermint Cream
liquor
before you started the the
run you know how cold it is up there oh
yeah in the north pole north pole north
pole and I want to thank you for being
here we we had to we had to do a little
dog do dog dog I had a breakdown who we
did oh just out oh right right yeah
that's that's when we're down to the
ship ship ship y got it got it you said
you said sip sip sip is that what you
just said Thank you bless you God yeah
of course yeah of
course that looks
familiar this look like yours no I'm
talking about the 60s oh oh
yeah kids this is how they used to have
fun were you shooting up back then oh
God is that a yes oh you had to cram
your dad at chimney how do you think I
get The
Bravery how do you think those elves
high on heroin yeah yeah yeah you got to
feel good going down faas in the
dragon that's so dark
dude have you ever been in a tunnel of
light that has Embers burning with a uog
never oh don't do it yeah I'd imagine
you have to be pretty you have to be
feeling pretty good to go down one of
those yeah seriously so so what's the
plan how many um mean you got to do a
lot of gifts per minute oh
God yep you tired of it man oh it's
exhausting people want the weird [__]
now day what do you like what's the
weirdest what's the weirdest gift you've
gotten someone l a lot of Americans want
OIC oh oh so I this shit's expensive it
is there it is yeah that's yeah oh zic
what else my ac1 is last
CH
what it's all right he's shut down a
little bit he's shut down a little bit
okay okay cool well what else did you
want to sit on his lap and ask him for a
gift me oh that that'd be great yeah ass
oh good good come on over here or do you
want me to go over there and it's
supposed to be a Michael right over here
oh I found it okay good I'll come over
there he has a hernia oh he's a hernia
there we go no don't worry I got the
mesh the what the B keeps it h keeps the
Insight inside and keeps keeps the let's
stop talking about your hernia why do I
have to sign a
Hipp yeah maybe okay cool now now now
now now a short boy I mean a little boy
what um he he calls everyone that it's
fine who has to change the light bulbs
in the ceiling every year smoke
detectors that's my [__] job so
anyway so how can I help assist your
thing what how can what what assist oh
assist my day okay I thought you said
dick for a second well that's your mind
yeah I guess um speaking of which a new
do you have ED
problems yeah like a box of blue Chu
that'd be kind of
nice okay uh sponsors blue Chu for the
big boy yeah okay okay there we go
anything else I can do here um I think
that's good that's it yeah how do you
like the tread tread I haven't used it
yet are you you ever going to yeah I
will good man good are you a fan are you
a fan of the Techno gy you want a little
bit of lap time no I'm just going with
the handshake okay because I just want
to let you know the reindeer have a beep
beep beep beep with you oh they do uhoh
moies they roll in the same herd man oh
got it they do and I want you to know
that Rudolph likes to get down with the
Moose oh every now and then he's in a
scat
what rain you know moose be moose [__]
yeah I guess moose be
[__] that's that I judge I don't
judge most people wouldn't get gifts if
I
judged well yeah well dude I me be Mrs
pause he had the breast cancer so it's a
sad story
what damn dude is she all is she all
right or thank you so much for grabbing
my sock I know I'll do it like I do
everything else you're on the clock we
got you guys some the some more presents
yeah cuz again we do with yourish shits
and I think it was only fair to do right
I think this one right yeah know that's
what's in there got it guys Merry
Christmas Mary feli [__] yeah [__] yeah
more gifts oh it's for s'mores it's to
make our s'mores with the Spotify
thing I think it's like an actual
fire this one's this one for me oh sorry
all right
sorry everything's going to work out
okay all right this one's for oh okay
there you
go we didn't want you to fight flicker
fire personal fire starting kit from the
California wild the Spotify
gift we said we get gift we didn't say
they'd be freaking
original wait did Spotify get you one of
these and then you just regifted it to
US GI a lot of crap dude I've been
around for 1725 years 52 years all the
endorsement packages are
amazing you should have hooked up with
me when I had the Coke thing back in the
yeah that would have been sick yeah when
was Santa doing cocaine oh I was the in
the liquid formula after the powdered
form
no that's what I actually wanted to ask
you for but oh Santa works for the
Sackler
[Laughter]
family is this the it's an air tag stalk
each other so we always know where you
are oh he sees you when you're sleeping
oh got it got it I also see you when you
golf that's true guilty H be on the golf
course Cody does like to do blow on the
golf course yeah yeah I'll make sure
sure to shove this up my ass when I go
golfing thank you Santa thank you guys
really appreciate it man um are you
going to make it out of here you'll be
all right give him a sack back do I have
to leave right now it's
okay yeah most the reindeer know how to
find their own placees did you want any
more of this I'll take that we don't
want to give him any more of that okay
all right no no no no
no you know you're always I know I know
300 years this [__]
I can replace you like that I know I
know his wife died of breast cancer man
I didn't say she was below ice oh she oh
she's still okay she's one look it's a
little treadmill you should get one of
those
huh that was a shot it was a shot it was
a shot I'm sorry I'll I'm sorry who
would have thought marry Grand
Smith who would have thought man I did
not know Timothy CH was an
elf I always thought he was tall well
thanks Santa thanks Santa appreciate it
how do you think he gets it all done
making all the toys delivering them I
think he's just [__] up the whole time
yeah yeah seems like he is yeah
screaming at his Fox cona kids make the
[__]
toys